[Music]
hello river babes and welcome back to
Sweetwater secrets your go-to source for
all things Riverdale
I'm your host Leon I Galera and today we
are celebrating the opening of Veronica
speakeasy and cheers babes not to worry
it's just cranberry juice and some
sparkling soda but you guys I'm here
because the YouTube gods have told me to
remind all of you that we've got two
episodes of sweet water coming at you
each week preview episodes every
Wednesday after shows every Thursday so
hit that subscribe button
basically we even get you addicted to
the show just like jingle jangle so just
embrace it I mean me too today is the
Sweetwater secrets preview for episode
303 chapter 38 as above so below and I'm
here to give you just a taste of what to
expect with my three tantalizing clues
plus calling all my fellow Shawnee
lovers yeah I know we've been going
through withdrawals so I've got a brand
new interview with tawny topaz herself
Vanessa Morgan and she's feeling all the
serpent T on our leading lady's but
first let's take a look back at your
hisses kisses and comments from our last
aftershow for episode 302
chapter 37 Fortune and men's eyes now
side note to all you river babes who are
sneaking peeks at Sweetwater secrets
while you're supposed to be paying
attention in school just don't get
caught okay
but first up Maggie Lin posted kisses to
all the parents being in the same room
and being civil creepy but civil I know
right and as I teased in last week's
preview clues it looks like our
Riverdale Ian's teens have inherited
their parents abilities to cover up deep
dark secrets also I wonder if the other
parents could feel the Fallas sexual
tension because you know it was strong
next Venis commented kisses to Jughead
trying to check in on Betty after
finding about her seizure I loved that
part too his reaction was just so sweet
meanwhile Audrey Harper wrote no offense
land but hisses to Kevin he's totally in
the wrong here kissing someone in the
hallway when you know they aren't openly
gay is a very selfish thing
do I also think that mousse might just
need some space from Kevin after that
happened I know I would I totally see
your point Audrey and I love that you
commented to tell me that now reminder
river babes you don't all have to agree
with my thoughts I welcome all of your
comments and opinions and I'll include
them I just want us to continue to keep
the sweetwater comments a very positive
place also you guys can always call me
out if I get something wrong for example
last week when I was referencing Josie's
maa Pussycats
I called them Valerie and Mallory but as
Rene Rodriguez pointed out in the
comments it's Valerie and melody not
Mallory woops sorry girls
but that also totally proves my point
where you at kitty cats women are
supposed to treat each other better than
this you River babes are also starting
to leave a ton of really great season 3
theories now Alexis Missouri wrote I
don't think the baby's floating was a
hallucination because been said at the
end quote you'll fly too am I the only
one who thinks something's up with that
no girl you are not the only one that
was weird
speaking of weird Chloe Tube commented
about Riverdale High's weird a student
and said I think Evelyn is somehow
causing the seizures because she's
always there when someone has a seizure
good observation and we're gonna start
to see Betty piece together the clues on
this very subject she's such a good
little Nancy Drew maybe there's a
connection between the seizures and
whatever happened don't leave moving
along Mirth martine added i really don't
get how veronica finds the time to run
pops visit archie frequently learn full
choreography in a day and focus on
school how isn't she
exhausted all the time I know right well
here's my theory
maybe she's a witch ok fine she's not a
witch but you know who is Sabrina
Spellman and here's my shameless plug
that my first episode of the witches
Council
out now so if you love Sweetwater
secrets which I think you do and you're
planning on watching the chilling
Adventures of Sabrina then you're going
to love my new series so please take a
look
okay shameless plug over now and lastly
alia M commented hisses - no show nyan
but Cheryl talking about her and Tony
going to Kali was amazing I know that my
fellow Shoni shippers are totally pissed
that Tony was m.i.a from last week's
episode so I have a magical treat for
you I caught up with Vanessa Morgan at
the chilling adventures of Sabrina
premiere red carpet and asked her to
dish that serpent sweetness take a look
at our chat fill me in on Shoney's
iconic road trip because I need the
details I'm bummed we didn't get to see
that I know I wish I had more details
I'm assuming it was iconic I'm assuming
it was amazing I hope that they actually
show some snippets from it or something
that would be the best yeah I think
they're just falling madly in love with
each other and enjoying each other's
company being young crazy teenagers what
are some upcoming Shoni scenes you can
choose for the fans we filmed one
yesterday it involved some sexy cat suit
we know that Tony can rock an amazing
cat suit we've seen that from their
iconic first kiss so many fans want this
crossover with Sabrina what have you
heard on it I heard like the possibility
of it I don't know if they ever would
but because I'm such a Sabrina fan I'm
like dying for it would you want Tony to
share a scene with ya represent Sabrina
what's still on your Tony topaz bucket
list getting to see my backstory where
my family's from enter motorcycle and my
motorcycle and I'm gonna do my
motorcycle license like Vanessa is gonna
do a motorcycle license before they in
there I love that she said that Cheryl
and Tony are falling madly in love with
each other but I need more what else are
you wanting to see from Tony this year
tell me in the comments but for now
let's take a look at what will be on our
screens in this week's episode in the
new promo for 303 chapter 38 as above so
below
roll it we're here to talk about you
tonight can be your first testimony
welcome to your first game we got a
problem what are you two hiding welcome
to the pit that's right daddy I'm
shaking you down oh my goodness
Cheryl sitting on jugheads throne
bedroom scenes for both Alice and bug
head Archie attacks and Veronica versus
Hyrum confrontation that's a lot to
process so I'm gonna take a page out of
princess ethylene Scripture and bestow
upon you three clues about episode 303
number one a connection we've been
waiting to see since this summer is
finally here
that don't blink you might miss it
number two suit up ladies three girls
are on the hunt for a certain season two
some things that I referenced at the
beginning of this video and number three
get ready for a first-time smooch I'm
not telling who and I think we'll end it
there thank you for watching the
Sweetwater secrets preview show and I'll
see you after you watch episode 303 for
sexy phallus scoop from H an emic new
farms group from Lilly Reinhardt and
more shocking surprises but for now
please give this video a like and then
hit the comments to see if you can crack
my three clues also what did you think
of Vanessa's show any comments do you
have a new Griffin's and gargoyles
theory oh and have you watched my first
episode of witches council cast your
spell and tell me what you think and
I'll see you soon river babes
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]